[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto ya lo dijeron esto ya lo dijeron
esto ya lo dijeron este se lo dijeron me
va a quedar otra que tratar de decirlo
de manera distinta
dicen
que para conocer a alguien es suficiente
con mirar sus zapatos
yo prefiero pensar que para conocer a
una persona es mejor mirar el recorrido
del camino de su vida y qué hizo con
todo lo vivido
y hablando de caminos y caminantes les
cuento una leyenda que se llama la
leyenda de los árboles andantes dice que
antes los árboles podían trasladarse de
un lugar a otro y lo hacían porque
estaban todo el tiempo buscando un mejor
lugar donde crecer y ser ellos mismos
pero como los árboles viven muchos años
se fueron volviendo como más sabios y
empezaron a permanecer más tiempo en el
mismo lugar y fue allí que ahondaron sus
raíces éste se extendieron sus ramas
dieron flores frutos semillas
y dicen también que desde ese entonces
no se vio nunca más a un árbol deambular
de un lugar a otro porque habían
descubierto que en el lugar donde les
tocó nacer tenían todo lo necesario para
crecer desarrollarse es decir habían
encontrado su lugar en el mundo
y dice también la leyenda al final que
las personas hoy somos como árboles
andantes que solemos andar de un lugar a
otro
como sin sentido porque todavía no
encontramos no descubrimos que en el
lugar donde estamos tenemos todo lo
necesario también para ser felices
hasta donde sabemos el anhelo más
profundo de la humanidad
por eso
acá está para cambiar
y se apretó solo
yo estoy convencido que para ser más
felices deberíamos ser más creativos y
es raro asociar estos dos términos
porque si miramos hoy día parecería como
que la felicidad está más asociada al
dinero o al poder este qué sé yo
y la creatividad está más asociada a
algo mágico que les agarra a los
artistas a los inventores a los niños a
los del departamento de marketing de la
empresa y se ponen a inventar cosas que
a veces sirven para algo no
pero yo creo que es en parte eso pero es
más
si ustedes buscan o yo que lo hice en
internet
aparece esta definición dentro de las
primeras cosas que aparecen
la creatividad es la capacidad de
generar nuevas ideas o conceptos a
partir de nuevas asociaciones entre
ideas y conceptos conocidos que
habitualmente producen soluciones
originales a mí me pasó que cuando la
leí en la primera vez es muy confusa
pero cuando la miré describía bien lo
que yo siento y viví que es la
creatividad dicho
en menos palabras podríamos decir
la creatividad es la capacidad que
tenemos de tomar ideas diferentes y
mezclarlas combinarlas de una manera
novedosa y obtener resultados para los
problemas o desafíos de la vida
cotidiana
ya que mencionó desafíos les cuento que
yo estoy casado
ya sé que tengo el anillo en el dedo
equivocado preso es otra historia de
esta casta mi señora hola querida
después llegó el pan y el desafío del
casamiento del matrimonio de la pareja
no es suficiente también tenemos tres
hijos que también están aquí
y en este momento
los ingresos económicos de la familia
dependen exclusivamente de mi trabajo y
yo soy artista así que imagínense el
desafío un día me encontré con una
persona y le contaba esto no de qué
estoy casado de que tengo hijos y me
dice
a qué te dedicas qué haces le digo con
orgullo soy escultor y me mira y me dice
y tu señora de que trabaja
yo me sentí medio incomprendido digamos
pero bueno les contaba también esto por
qué
un día viene en nuestra hija mayor lucía
y
y me dice esa frase creo que es una de
las frases terribles que los padres
tenemos que escuchar a veces y queremos
evitarla pero llega ese papi estoy
aburrida y bueno para mí es un desafío
eso entonces le digo puedes dibujar algo
y me dice no sé qué dibujar
y yo le retrucó bueno dibuja te hago
pensando que no sabes que dibujar
entonces hace el dibujito ella esté
pensando y ahí empieza a ella vaya a
arrancar con su creatividad y como ella
estaba pensando que estaba pensando que
estaba pensando así es una protección al
infinito de ella pensándose y después
dice porque será que las ideas no pueden
llegar hasta mí no será que hay un campo
de fuerza que no las deja entrar a las
ideas y empieza a dibujar las ideas ven
el foquito que apareció ahí una idea
otra idea otra más idea repetida ideas
saltando ideas rebotando pero las ideas
no podían entrar
y ahí le da otra vuelta de tuerca a la
creatividad y dice qué clase de ideas
pueden ser que no están llegando hasta
donde estoy yo será acaso una idea
descabellada
una idea con cabello
o tal vez no tengo ni la menor idea o
tal vez esa es la idea
o puedo tener una idea dando vueltas o
una gran idea
una lluvia de ideas con una idea de bajo
consumo y nos mató porque dibujo el
foquito de bajo consumo cambio de
personaje
idea de último momento viene llegando a
lo último una idea más la que la recta
una idea chiquita
una idea bomba ven trae el contador
descontando ahí pipí pipí una idea
original la idea genial
y así fueron ideas infinitas fíjense en
los conceptos que van apareciendo en el
dibujo no el concepto del infinito en la
idea infinita
esta idea real buena idea idea tonta
este y bueno ese trabajo le fue ocupando
toda su tarde
y nos contagió al resto de la familia
porque todos empezamos a sugerir ideas y
como las podía representar después se
encargaba de ellas y las ponía no es
cierto y creo que daría la riqueza de
esa sola experiencia para formular toda
una charla y viendo esto y lo que pudo
haber salido y lo que salió pero yo
quiero rescatar principalmente el hecho
de que esté nuestra hija que pudo haber
experimentado ella que a veces frente a
ese estancamiento que es el aburrimiento
esa nada lo que necesitamos es dar un
paso y empezar a dejar que las ideas
aparezcan y cuando dejamos hacer eso
nosotros los grandes también la
creatividad puede llevarnos a lugares
impensados no únicamente en estado
emocional sino geográficamente también
podemos terminar cayendo en cualquier
país en poco tiempo y hacer cosas
impensadas
nosotros como padres optamos por
fomentar la creatividad es como nuestra
apuesta con nuestros hijos
pero también tengo que decir que veo con
preocupación que muchos chicos de hoy
este que pueden acceder a una formación
que les permita ser los líderes de
empresas o de gobiernos dentro de unas
décadas se están formando en entornos
muy poco creativos como van a ser
después para saber qué hacer con todo lo
que la vida les puso en las manos
después de esos 30 años estudio cómo van
a hacer para gestionar todo lo que
tienen
pero
volviendo digamos de esas reflexiones
con respecto a mi a mi infancia ya cómo
viví yo la creativa estuvo muy presente
porque como muchos creo que como la
mayoría tuve una infancia una infancia
difícil fue hermosa pero me tocó vivir
en un contexto complicado
complicado en el sentido de carencias
económicas complicados en el sentido de
pérdidas dolorosas a muy temprana edad
vivíamos en un contexto rural lo cual
tiene muchas ventajas pero también
tenéis la desventaja de estar
desconectado la tecnología
tampoco había mucha tecnología estamos
hablando de 40 años atrás casi internet
celulares ni la televisión apenas que
había hay un canal este que no trasmitía
todo el día tampoco no
en ese contexto la creatividad fue mi
refugio y también fue la puerta que me
permitió a mí ir explorando mis
potenciales por ejemplo
en esa época se usaba que todos los
chicos del barrio jueguen juntos no es
cierto hoy día ya es más difícil por la
inseguridad pero en esa época jugábamos
todos juntos pero yo era el más
chiquitito el menor
y jugaba un montón pero muchas veces la
quedaba excluido porque como ustedes
sabrán los más chiquititos a veces nos
ponemos medio cargos o que lo digan
siendo los que son hermanos mayores acá
en la sala y tuvieron que jugar con el
más chiquito así que me quedaba un poco
excluido
pero ahí en esos ratos de soledad mi
papá me enseñó a dibujar me enseñó a
prepararme a los árboles fui conociendo
los árboles creando mundos de fantasía y
también conocí la lectura la pasión por
la lectura leyendo historietas
historietas de superhéroes de guerreros
y como me gustaba dibujar dibujaba sus
superhéroes y a muy temprana edad sin
saberlo empecé a dominar la anatomía
humana que fue una de las bases de lo
que hoy es mi camino artístico pero
gracias a haber tenido un adulto que me
motivo y la posibilidad de desarrollar
la creatividad
bueno también como éramos una familia
muy numerosa
los ejemplos que yo tenía eran
variadísimos había buenos ejemplos y
ejemplos no tan buenos pero también por
ver las cosas desde otro ángulo ya en
aquella edad puede darme cuenta que un
mal ejemplo no es algo que yo tengo que
repetir hacer mal ejemplo es un perfecto
buen ejemplo de lo que yo no quiero
hacer o ser cuando sea adulto o cuando
sea más grande
bueno después seguir creciendo siempre
con esa óptica de ver las cosas desde
otro punto y se escuela industrial soy
profesor de educación física participé
en muchos grupos de jóvenes este green o
el matrimonio los hijos y todo eso se
fue combinando y dando forma a lo que
soy hoy
entonces yo hoy afirmó que la
creatividad ya no es mi refugio hoy es
una de mis fortalezas porque me ayudó a
ser quien soy hoy
y cuando cuando pienso en nuestros
chicos en nuestros niños no solo los que
tenemos hijos nuestros niños
creo que la creatividad es uno de los
mayores legados que podemos dejarles más
allá del conocimiento más allá del
dinero tenemos que trabajar por eso
porque estoy convencido de que es
fundamental para ir formando nuestra
identidad
porque nos permite
ir integrando todos los recuerdos
emociones y conocimientos darles forma
darles un sentido que nos ayuda no
solamente en la vida cotidiana sino nos
reconcilia con nuestra historia y nos
permite pararnos en el presente y decir
aquí estoy y entiendo tengo todo esto
tiene un sentido alguien me dijo un día
porque esos escultores y yo lo digo
porque no serlo sería negar toda mi
historia hoy yo tengo que ser escultor
si en otro momento las circunstancias
hacen que se combinen diferentes más las
partes que componen ser otra cosa pero
hoy tengo que ser escultor
y acá hay un punto fundamental de la con
respecto a la creatividad que a veces
como que la menospreciamos y creemos que
solamente sirve para solucionar cosas de
la vida cotidiana o poder vender mejor
un producto o entretener
pero si fuese solo eso uno puede
contratar un creativo que le solucione
todos los problemas que piense por uno y
sería feliz pero vemos que no nos
funciona eso no lo vemos nadie es feliz
solo por contratar alguien que le
solucione los problemas cotidianos lo
que necesitamos es saber cosas más
profundas pero nadie puede contratar a
alguien para que le diga quién es
yo no puedo contratar a alguien que me
diga quién soy porque lo que yo soy y
acá hago una parte así tipo filosófica
lo que yo soy no depende de qué cosas
buenas o malas me pasaron en la vida
ni de la cantidad de títulos ni cosas
que se ven digamos ni los premios ni el
dinero lo que me define es qué hago con
todo es cómo hago que todo eso
interactúe de manera positiva para
generar un ser único
yo ustedes alguien se acuerda que no soy
sin zapatos
hoy nadie aprendimos otra cosa si usted
van a la conferencia sin zapatos si
tienen algo más o menos interesante para
decir a los diez minutos de la nadie le
mira a los pies así que no se preocupen
por comprar zapatos
preocúpense porque van a decir
este
bueno les decía que la creatividad nos
permite integrar todo lo vivido porque
si nosotros nos vamos integrando las
cosas de nuestra vida empezamos a tener
una personalidad fragmentada cuando esto
ocurre empezamos a enfermarnos nos
empiezan las angustias
y bueno y se pone complicada las cosas
porque nos hace daño hacemos daños
nosotros a nosotros como decía también
el orador anterior andamos por ahí
tratando de soltar lo que no nos gusta o
lo que nos molesta y no nos damos cuenta
que la clave no es solo soltar la clave
es integrar es incorporar es asumir y
crecer y la creatividad nos permite
hacer esa interacción es eso más
profundamente
sobre todo hoy que estamos en un
contexto como hablaban en la primer
charla en un cambio vertiginoso y
continuo ya no tenemos nada seguro que
sea yo estoy parado acá y acá pasa algo
y vuelvo y el círculo rojo ya no está
no tengo techo vivimos como en una
intemperie existencial
'hemos
descubierto e inventado más cosas de las
que somos capaces de usar sabiamente no
les parece fíjense que tenemos
tecnología que nos promete
y ahorrar tiempo porque nos facilitan
las tareas que se yo pero yo me pregunto
y les pregunto a ustedes ese tiempo que
ahorramos dónde está
de ser un mono
quién tiene ese tiempo a quién le sobra
así que algo algo nos está faltando en
todo esto hemos inventado muchas cosas
pero no estamos usando la creatividad
para ver cómo usarlas de manera sabia
fíjense que por ejemplo una persona de
50 años que dedicó no de 70 años digamos
que dedico 50 años de su vida a formarse
que tiene todos los títulos y toda la
formación en cualquier campo de ciencias
de repente puede resultar obsoleta hoy
es transformarse en caballos como decían
antes porque ya hay una máquina que
puede hacer todo eso en menos tiempo sin
enfermarse
aparte más barato para una compañía
desarrollar una máquina que pagarle los
estudios a una persona durante 50 años
es más rápido y la máquina no se muere
no se enferma no pide licencia
entonces
yo estoy convencido que tenemos que
desarrollar más la creatividad para
poder adaptarnos sobre todo en este
tiempo donde el que no se adapta ya
queda afuera pero a veces quedará afuera
no es tan malo porque si les pasa como
me pasó a mí cuando era chico quedar
afuera a veces está la oportunidad de
crear vos tu propia realidad que no es
una realidad imposible es una realidad
que no se estaba viendo solamente
y ahora
ya salir del círculo me voy a venir para
este lado
y acá yo tengo que ir hablando mientras
me pongo las cosas porque si no no queda
mucho silencio pero bueno la vida nos va
dando este cosas experiencias
vamos acumulando recuerdos conocimiento
muchas de las experiencias tienen que
ver directamente con decisiones que
fuimos tomando nosotros en diferentes
momentos no son consecuencias de
nuestras decisiones
pero hay muchas otras que no que las
digamos como de rebote no nosotros
tenemos nada que ver en encontrarnos en
esa situación
digamos que
son como un efecto colateral hay que
tenemos que asumir
pero lo que no podemos no asumir es lo
que les decía antes que hacemos con eso
que la vida nos va poniendo en las manos
por ejemplo yo ahora la vida me está
dando unos zapatos reforzados para de
protección
estas son perneras anti cortes porque no
creo que quede muy bien que una persona
se corte una pierna en un 3
e
también tengo un par de guantes ahí
voy a hacer el famoso truco de cortar en
dos una persona con la motosierra
así que voy a necesitar un voluntario
del público por favor
el seguro cubre todo iguales no se
preocupen
no retomando el tema y hablando en serio
ahora que estoy terminando de equipar me
la vida me fue poniendo muchas cosas en
el camino
yo las tomé a todas
y decidí que dentro de otras cosas
lo que hago son esculturas así que vamos
a hacer algo a ver qué sale
[Música]
no hay nadie adentro no se preocupen
[Aplausos]
hoy lo que yo hago me trajo acá
ustedes si no me equivoco le han
entregado un tienen en su mano un
pedacito de madera o en su bolsillo en
su cartera ya no sé dónde está ese
pedacito de madera hasta la semana
pasada era parte de este tronco
digamos que en su configuración anterior
eran un árbol
y hoy
mi intención es que sea en sus manos mi
esperanza de que era aquí y ustedes se
lleven algo un pedacito
un desafío una idea
una ilusión
y también tienen el papelito con algunas
de las ideas del dibujo de lucía no sé
si las encontraron en el dibujo para
hacerles acordar que para tener una idea
creativa muchas veces lo único que hay
que hacer es dejar que las ideas vayan
apareciendo aunque sean locas
descabelladas o con cabello
y existe existe otra versión del final
del cuento de los árboles andantes en
realidad es otra traducción posible
porque
la tradujeron de otra manera y dice que
las personas somos si en realidad
árboles andantes
pero que podemos movernos de un lado al
otro sin perder nuestra identidad
siempre y cuando recordemos cuáles son
nuestras raíces
[Aplausos]
[Música]